[Música]
como 15 detalles en la primera parte no
bastaron hoy veremos otros 15 detalles
en videojuegos como ya saben esto trata
de mostrar detalles que los
desarrolladores ponen en sus videojuegos
para ayudar a animación del juego a
veces solo por karina sus creaciones a
pesar de que si algunas o la gran
mayoría de veces no tienen nuestro
propósito aparte solo bueno estar ahí el
punto es que son geniales y la envidia
el juego debo decir que esta serie me
gusta bastante porque son cosas en las
que muy poca gente se fija de mostrar
estas cosas en las que alguien puso
mucho de su tiempo es bastante genial
así que bueno vamos a continuar con
otros 15 detalles
[Música]
comenzamos donde lo dejamos en el vídeo
pasado no en huevos de caballo en red
dead redemption 2 y es que este juego
además de hacer un bello mundo abierto
es uno de los juegos con más detalles de
los últimos tiempos en serio es que se
nota el cariño que tuvieron al hacerlo
donde es allí bastante genial e
inmersivo es que cuando acabas con
alguien y deja su cuerpo tirado en la
calle no sólo desaparecerá con la
mayoría de juegos sino que llegarán
hombres del sheriff 21 que recogerán los
cuerpos y se los llevarán
ya este es el último deber del día lo
prometo pero esto sí es bastante
asombroso porque cuando muere algún
animal ya sea por hora tuya o cosa de la
naturaleza el cuerpo como dije no
desaparecerá problemas de eso se
descompone con el paso del tiempo de una
manera realista es genial perturbador
pero genial
hideo kojima es alguien que dedica mucho
tiempo y cariño en sus creaciones y con
alguien tan excéntrico como él no debe
faltar detalles en su saga insignia el
metal gira más específicamente en su
segunda parte si está donde nos hicieron
pensar que vamos a volver a jugar con
snail nos metieron a raiden así de
sorpresa los
a través del juego de vez en cuando
verás cubetas llenas de hielo si les
disparas brazos detalle bastante
necesario es que los cubos de hielo
derramados comienzan a derretirse de una
manera realista
assassin's creed 3 para mí es uno de los
mejores juegos de la franquicia pero la
remasterización que le hicieron el juego
este año fue una [ __ ]
vamos que fue algo totalmente necesario
no lo entiendo la razón de por qué si es
que el juego ni tan viejo es además de
que la verdad a pesar de que si
mejoraron algunas cosas como los fondos
la distancia dibujado y la iluminación
la verdad que las mejoras parecen poca
cosa en comparación a los fallos que
tuvieron siendo honestos una de las
peores remasterización es que hay lugar
generes mucho mejor pero créame tirando
tema porque lo que si le agregaron fue
detalles bastante geniales y uno de
estos detalles es que si es para hacer
que una cara el ruido el jesús tara
claras que se quiere paralizar unos
segundos como pasa en la vida real ya
que si no sabía si a las cabras las
asustamos mucho se paralizan
este detalle sí creo que muchos lo
vieron notar lo mejor es que es bastante
más obvio de lo que usualmente pongo en
esta lista ya conocemos a mortal kombat
es ese ser y donde te pueden romper una
pierna tres veces pero tú sigues
peleando como si nada
mortal kombat se trata de brutalidad y
hacerle cuánto daño sea posible al
enemigo el mortal kombat 9 algo curioso
es que dependiendo de qué tanto daño
recibas en una pelea las series serán
reflejadas en tu personaje
para este si necesito que hagamos un
poco de historia que la mayoría deben
saberlo pero algunos no en batman hay un
personaje llamado bárbara gordon más
conocido como el oráculo este personaje
es una chica en silla de ruedas que
ayuda a batman consiguiendo la edad luz
y cosas importantes mediante la
computadora ella que en silla de ruedas
porque el joker disparo en la columna y
es un persona importante en el último
juego de la trilogía de arkham de batman
arkham night y como saben en ese juego
de una mecánica interesante que es la
visión de detective que le da la
capacidad batman de ver a través de
ciertos objetos y descubrir pistas más
fácilmente la cosa es que si esa es la
visión de detective con barbara si pones
atención verás que se puede ver el lugar
en donde su columna que hoy reparable
half life 2 es un juego que marcó una
generación entera de videojuegos tanto
que desde hace años los fan estamos
pidiendo una secuela que probablemente
nunca llegue pero en bethesda empecé a
trabajar en half life 3 no tiene algo
mejor en el segundo juego le pusieron
inteligencia artificial a las cucarachas
así como dieron estos juegos conocido
por su revolucionaria inteligencia
artificial en insectos y es que en el
juego las cucarachas actúan de una
manera bastante realista huyendo de ti
escondiéndose cuando hay luz acercándose
así en un pedazo de carne y con toda
clase inútiles detalles como
comportamientos igual a temperatura y
cosas así a pesar de ser completamente
inútil es algo increíble considerando
los años que tienes al face 2
en un rastro de tom raider hay bastantes
escenarios con nieve pero en este juego
la nieve más que estar ahí sólo para
crear el ambiente puede interactuar con
las físicas de tu personaje pues él hace
un ambiente nevado verás que la nieve
salir al cabello y la ropa de lara y si
entras después a un ambiente más cálido
le miento personaje se derretirá algo
parecido lo que vemos con kratos en el
vídeo anterior
hablando de kratos como saben en el
nuevo god of war casi todos los
escenarios están cubiertos con nieve y
es bueno saber que la gran importancia
esta ambientación porque además de lo
que hable de él en el vídeo anterior
otro detalle genial es que cuando
caminas en lugares nevados con tus
huellas quitarás la nieve revelando el
suelo que la nieve cubría
no
si te pido que pienses en kratos claro
el trato es del cuarto juego que es lo
que más resalta en el personaje claro
sus vendajes digo su barba que pasó a
ser un cachito hacer una barba completa
que lea una obra más madura el personaje
pero más que hacer un elemento nuevo
para kratos esta nueva barba reaccionar
clima moviéndose al son del viento
[Música]
entre las topos de grasa una parte donde
se tratará de recoger un juguete de una
tienda abandonada para recuperar algo de
su niñez que el virus le arrebató pero
su padre no lo deja y el niño debe tirar
el juguete si luego de eso le das la
espalda a él y ella en un acto tierno de
compasión recogerá en secreto el juguete
que querías ampararse lo más tarde
vamos a pagar
dad
a ambos
[Música]
17 nivel 7 a pasar de tener bastantes
cambios sin opinión bastante evidente
los fans es uno de mis juegos favoritos
de toda la franquicia ya que tiene
bastantes cambios que lo remontan de
nuevo a sus raíces del horror y una
novedad de este título fue el cambio
primera persona en donde podemos ver
muchos más detalles
uno de estos detalles que me gustó mucho
es que cuando los insectos de margaret
baker te atacan y revisas tu mano
notarás que en la piel de tu personaje
se reflejan las picaduras
ah
en varios ríos 5 hay algunos mapas en
donde encontraremos lugares cubiertos
por nieve pero si las rojas algo
contundente por ejemplo una granada
podemos ver cómo la nieve cae del techo
por impactos causados
la segunda parte de watts 2 limpio el
nombre de esta saga ya que fue un juego
que a comparación de su primera entrega
se gustó mucho además de que es
innegable que tiene mucha inspiración de
gta 5 porque se parecen muchísimo como
por ejemplo en la opción de usar
teléfonos en el juego más
específicamente en este caso la cámara
lo divertido es que si estás en la calle
tomándote una foto los npc posarán o
actuarán de maneras divertidas frente a
la cámara
en spider-man de playstation 4 vas a
estar mente constantemente así que pobre
petersen agitar bastante cosa que los
desarrolladores tomaron muy en cuenta ya
que en el juego cada conversación que
tengas tiene dos versiones una común y
normal que se usará si después de
hermana está quieto o moviéndose
lentamente y otra versión de los mismos
diálogos pero que se usará cuando
spider-man esté moviéndose esto hará que
los diálogos que usualmente serían
bastante comunes no tiene el cansancio
la dificultad para hablar de peter
mientras de columbia por nueva york
que
[Música]
con un pequeño extra tenemos un detalle
que me parece bastante genial y de los
mejores en metal gear solid 5 the
phantom paint añadieron un gran realismo
tanto que con el pasar del tiempo y
entre cada misión tenías que bañarte
claro porque estar corriendo por el
desierto y asesinando soldados todo el
día no dejarte olor a rosas precisamente
pero si decidía no bañarte por un largo
periodo de tiempo los soldados en la
base comenzarán a evitarte ya notar que
apestas además que aparte de estar más
sucio que la oreja de un banco tienes
buenos lazos con quiet al regresar de
una misión te va a saltar una cinemática
donde todos los soldados están cansados
de tu mal olor y quiet te pide que te
bañes con ella en esta suculenta escena
o
snake
yus
ojo que este segundo lo he hecho yo este
suv es así sólo cinemática ya no ha
hecho nada o al sume
gracias por ver el vídeo espero que esta
segunda parte les haya gustado tanto
como a mí me gusta hacerla si conocen
más detalles como estos o quisieran una
tercera parte de cambio no saber en los
comentarios
pronto entrar a estudiar de nuevo así
que tal vez el contenido del canal ya no
sea tan frecuente pero seguiré con los
vídeos no se preocupen intentar entrar
los constantemente no olviden seguirme
en twitter y aquí las notificaciones del
canal era la primera parte del vídeo
para que la habían sino en visto ya pues
de todos hasta la próxima
y
[Música]